[Music]  you posted a picture Hillary Clinton's  everywhere these days promoting her book  and she was at a book signing and she  took a picture with Katy Perry yeah and  you decided to I guess photo bomb in the  background and I loved this photograph I  had this I mean first of all your whole  aura that you're putting off is  fantastic yeah I don't know what was  happening I I went to a book signing and  there I had these weird glasses on and I  saw them taking a picture and there was  just a it was a game-time decision that  I made because I could I could tell that  there was a sliver in between them and I  could just quickly pop my head up was  Katy Perry oh okay with this she was not  psyched about it I told her I was like  Katy I totally like photobomb your  picture and she was like why'd you do  that  and I was like I don't know yeah and  then I told Hillary and she was like I'm  running for president don't tell anyone  [Applause]  [Laughter]  you